Good Clinical Practice (GCP) is an
international ethical and scientific
quality standard for designing, conducting,
recording and reporting clinical trials that
involve the participation of human subjects.
Regardless of whether a clinical trial is a large,
multi-center study in patients or a small clinical
pharmacological study in healthy subjects,
the relevant GCP standard should be followed by
the sponsoring company of the healthcare product,
the investigators, the ethics committees
and any clinical research organizations.
Companies undertaking a clinical trial must
follow certain procedures and practices
Companies undertaking a clinical trial should
develop written procedures for implementing GCP.
Such procedures may include, but
are not limited to, the following:
• Investigator site selection
• Regulatory document collection,
review and submission
• Financial disclosure
• Investigator site initiation
• Investigational product
distribution and tracking
• Clinical monitoring of investigator site
• Investigator site close-out
• Safety reporting
• Quality assurance audits
• Required documents for
study master file and document retention
• Vendor qualification and oversight (for
example, contract research organization)
• Indemnity, compensation and insurance
Good Clinical Practice and the
International Conference on Harmonization
Prior to the GCP guidance document developed by
the International Conference on Harmonization
(ICH), different jurisdictions had different
guidelines relating to the conduct of clinical
trials. With the introduction of ICH GCP,
the conduct of clinical trials globally has
become more uniform and practicable. Today, the
implementation of ICH good clinical practice in
most jurisdictions is reasonably similar and the
vast majority of the regulations are the same.
Despite the effort of ICH, there
still exists some local differences.
For example, the US no longer adheres to
the Declaration of Helsinki in its entirety,
because the declaration considers
placebo-controlled trials unethical
in cases where an active drug is available. New
privacy regulations in the EU and the financial
disclosure requirements in the US are also making
the clinical trial landscape more complicated.
Healthcare product developers should therefore
work to ICH in the context of local regulations.
GCP principles for clinical trials
The regulations, guidance and industry
standards that make up Good Clinical Practice are
intended to provide assurance that the rights,
safety and well-being of clinical trial subjects
are protected. GCP is also intended to assure
that the research yields quality scientific data.
Fundamentally, Good Clinical Practice requires:
• Oversight of the local ethics committee(s)
• Verification of the
investigator’s qualifications
• A study protocol, investigator’s brochure,
informed consent, and the documentation that
is essential for undertaking a clinical trial
• Monitoring of the clinical trial
• Submission of reports and maintenance of records
• The ICH GCP lays out the responsibilities of
the ethics committees, sponsors and investigators.
The core principles of ICH Good
Clinical Practice are presented below.
Thirteen core principles of GCP
1. Ethical principles: Clinical
trials should be conducted in accordance
with the ethical principles that have their
origin in the Declaration of Helsinki,
and that are consistent with GCP and
the applicable regulatory requirement(s).
2. Favourable benefit(s) vs. risk(s): Before
a trial is initiated, foreseeable
risks and inconveniences should be
weighed against the anticipated benefit for
the individual trial subject and society.
A trial should be initiated and continued only
if the anticipated benefits justify the risks.
3. Subject’s rights: The rights, safety,
and well-being of the trial subjects
are the most important considerations and should
prevail over interests of science and society.
4. Adequate supporting data: The available
nonclinical and clinical information on an
investigational product should be adequate
to support the proposed clinical trial.
5. Scientifically sound protocol: Clinical
trials should be scientifically sound,
and described in a clear, detailed protocol.
6. Independent ethics committee oversight: A
trial should be conducted in compliance with the
protocol that has received prior institutional
review board (IRB)/independent ethics
committee (IEC) approval/favourable opinion.
7. Medical care by qualified investigator: The
medical care given to, and medical decisions
made on behalf of, subjects should always be
the responsibility of a qualified physician or,
when appropriate, of a qualified dentist.
8. Qualified personnel: Each individual
involved in conducting a trial should be qualified
by education, training, and experience to perform
his or her respective task(s).
9. Informed
consent: Freely given informed consent
should be obtained from every subject
prior to clinical trial participation.
10. Record-keeping: All clinical trial information
should be recorded, handled, and stored in
a way that allows its accurate reporting,
interpretation and verification.
11. Subject confidentiality:
The confidentiality of records that could identify
subjects should be protected, respecting the
privacy and confidentiality rules in accordance
with the applicable regulatory requirement(s).
12. GMP manufacturing of the investigational
product: Investigational products should be
manufactured, handled, and stored
in accordance with applicable good
manufacturing practice (GMP). They should be
used in accordance with the approved protocol.
13. Quality assurance & monitoring:
Systems with procedures that assure
the quality of every aspect of
the trial should be implemented.
Summary
In summary, GCP helps protect the rights,
safety and well-being of clinical trial
subjects, and assures quality scientific data.